nearly two months after getting hit by a
jet ski a little girl from las vegas now
on the road to recovery
seven-year-old isabella bohannon
sustained severe head trauma orco manna
caught up with the family
who is speaking now now for the very
first time it is a story you'll only see
right here on eight news now orco well
brian isabella bohannon is a fighter
the bubbly and energetic seven-year-old
was clinging to life
just weeks ago but her father tells me
she's now slowly
but surely making progress with her
recovery
we were just in the wrong place at the
wrong time april 3rd
2021 is a date michael bohannon will
never
forget that's when his seven-year-old
daughter isabella was seriously injured
after a jet ski hit her
while she was playing on the shores of
the colorado river by bullhead city
arizona
that was a day our lives you know took a
drastic turn
isabella suffered severe brain injuries
and underwent surgery at a hospital in
salt lake city
it was unclear what would happen next
but isabella is making incredible
progress
she is staying very positive she is now
back at sunrise children's hospital in
las vegas no longer in a coma and off
her ventilator
but she's starting from scratch she's
learning how to take care of herself
again
brush teeth walk stand talk
eat she's learning how to do everything
all over again and she's taking it in
stride
as isabella works to get better the
bohannon family is urging
everyone on or near a jet ski this
summer to be careful
that's what we do for fun but everybody
wants to go home safe at the end of the
day
and while the road to recovery is long
isabella's loved ones say
she's resilient she gets up every day
accepts
life for what it is right now and keeps
moving forward and
you know we couldn't ask for anything
more
we're all rooting for her isabella's
father tells me the next stage of her
recovery
involves continuing to build up her
physical strength and
improve her communication skills live in
the studio orca mana 8 news now